buonasera a tutti
sono qui stasera per porvi una domanda
quanto tempo dedicate durante le vostre
giornate all immaginazione non parlo di
sogni desideri voglia di far altro parlo
di immaginazione
stravolgete mai la realtà che li
circonda
provate mai a sentire annusare guardare
le cose con se fosse la prima volta
lo so il tempo è poco durante le nostre
giornate da dedicare all immaginazione
eppure nella difficoltà nel non riuscirò
a trovare del tempo per farlo io
riscontro la difficoltà di abbinò di
abbattere barriere e invece la grande
capacità di costruire differenze e
marginalità
io ho fatto spesso i conti con la mia
iperattività immaginativa soprattutto
quando la realtà cisco se quando si è
scontrata con la realtà è però in non
abbandonarla mi ha permesso di varcare i
limiti personali ed esterni molto
importanti
crescere in sicilia in una città come la
mia mazara del vallo ci pone di fronte a
delle situazioni e delle circostanze
uniche e molto contrastanti e strano
forse direte voi ma crescere con la
costante sensazione che ci sia qualcosa
di profondamente ingiusto nel luogo in
cui vivi che le cose non cambiano o che
peggio non possono cambiare rafforza la
struttura della tua immaginazione e ti
porta a creare una storia partendo dalla
fine dal traguardo io immagino una
sicilia che
perché farlo in un territorio dove
sembrano mancare le premesse per poter
avere orizzonti più ampi ma soprattutto
da dove iniziare e come farlo
proverò a rispondere a queste domande
molto importanti per me raccontandovi un
pezzettino della mia vita una storia che
piena di errori
assolutamente non lineare ma che a me
piace definire resistente inizia nel
2013 a padova gli studiavo da tre anni
nella facoltà di lettere e nonostante
vivesse lì da tre anni quei luoghi non
mi appartenevano ma soprattutto nutrivo
costantemente e giornalmente una
necessità di cambiamento e soprattutto
veniva nutrita quando salivo sull'aereo
e salutavo i miei genitori e andavo via
lì veniva nutrita da una porta un
profondo senso di ingiustizia
l'ingiustizia di non poter scegliere
dove vivere e sembrerà strano e più ma
io ho sempre voluto vivere in sicilia e
quindi mi sono chiesta come posso
contribuire al cambiamento cosa posso
fare per portare cambiamento ed una sera
probabilmente mentre preparavo il caffè
per studiare su tradotte
ho provato a rispondere a rispondermi
dalla creatività
creatività deriva dal latino creare e il
suffisso invita venuta un'attitudine in
particolare l'attitudine alla creazione
è qualcosa che abbiamo tutti e che vanno
trita e che ha tantissimi colori
differenti
ma per me rappresenta la capacità di
adattarsi alle circostanze e di adattare
le circostanze a sé e se è vero che è il
cambiamento parte da persone creative
costruire e creare un luogo che le
contenesse che le lasciasse libero di
poter esprimersi era il punto di
partenza
o forse l'obiettivo finale
dopo sette anni questo luogo per me
systems si chiama periferica e si trova
in via dell'acquedotto 15 a mazara del
vallo
ma esiste soprattutto dentro le persone
che lo hanno attraversato abitato
trasformato perché mi sono chiesta
perché quando comunichi un obiettivo con
forze d'amore ti accorgi che le persone
sono in grado di fare cose straordinarie
che gli incontri generano gesti
incontrollabili e che luoghi sono di
tutti e che tutti possiamo lasciare il
segno
per i veri che è stata molte cose per me
è stata rifugio è stata motore è stato
elemento disturbante storia e
trasformazione perché abbiamo
trasformato un vuoto urbano in
particolare un ex cava di tufo del 1800
ed un ex asilo degli anni 80 in quel
luogo che vi dicevo prima
valorizzando e tenendo in considerazione
il patrimonio storico naturalistico e
culturale contenuto nelle cave della
nostra città
ma è stata soprattutto
contenitore
contenitore che ha inglobato
generato e poi portato cambiamento ed è
stato un cambiamento a regia collettiva
mi piace definirlo quello che si è
creato e questi crea quando si lavora
sulla relazione spazi comunità l'abitare
inizia ad esprimere cura senso di
responsabilità e gli spazi si inizia ad
immaginarli insieme
l'immaginazione passa da essere
un'azione singola e personale ad essere
collettiva e condivisa e quando
l'immaginazione diventa collettiva per
me si varcano le frontiere dello stato
delle cose così come sono e si inizia ad
immaginare gli spazi insieme a nostra
misura in base ai nostri bisogni
quindi per me è necessario la nostra
vostra mentre creativa creativa che è in
grado di rompere gli schemi
dell'esperienza e di
divertirsi nel trovare all'interno del
problema l'opportunità
periferica nasce e si sviluppa in un
periodo in cui la normalità era
l'aggregazione gli abbracci e le strette
di mano in questa normalità puntata che
tutti stiamo vivendo periferica e tutti
i luoghi che come lei hanno reagito per
me rappresentano uno stato d'animo che
porto con me e che riporterò nelle cose
che farò in futuro ed è e si racchiude
nel fare insieme
perché fare insieme sta alla base non
solo della nostra sopravvivenza ma della
nostra stessa esistenza e se torno al
traguardo alla fine della storia che io
sto ancora continuando a scrivere
io immagino una sicilia che costruisce
condivide ed immagina insieme perché
immaginare e rivoluzionare noi stessi ed
i luoghi in cui viviamo
[Applauso]